we have adapted two sets of conclusions
on tax transparency and on climate
financing we exchanged views on the
so-called pay for bi fees directive
proposal to crack down on via T throat
against the EU budget using criminal law
many states are open to continue
discussions on calibration of the pmf
you proposal which can help us fight an
illicit texts behavior on you on a
national level and also the crossbow
factor as well as threshold limits where
I mentioned by several member states as
important limits for reaching of
compromise we continue to encourage
member states to implement essential
structural reforms to make our economies
more modern more competitive and
underpinned by effective social fabric
the Commission outlined to ministers a
proposed European fund for sustainable
development building on the investment
plan for Europe it aims to support
social and economic infrastructure and
assamese not least by removing obstacles
to private investment in Africa and he
used neighboring countries with an input
of three points certified billion from
EU budget and European development pond
say a IP would support guarantees and
other financial instruments in support
of private investment so that the EAP
can mobilize up to 44 44 billion of
investments